look man i'm i'm getting really
really sick and tired of this news cycle
i think the democrats
are panicking and panicking maybe isn't
the right word for it
i think the democrats are probably in
full-on
mental breakdown over the fact that
they are losing support from the black
community yeah as referenced by
that documentary we talked about the
other day i think from the entire
community
not just well rasmussen has uh trump's
support at 41
among all likely black voters oh wow so
to see the sheer
level of ra like racial news to me
is like it is insane it is insane it is
insane
the cdc 1200 employees demanding they
declare racism a public health crisis
like what the what what is this this
this news cycle it's just
absolutely ridiculous yeah it is like
it's it's it's everything
taken up i would say take them to 11 but
it's like 50. it's like they
rip the knob off every story i look up
on uh uh
you know now the top story is that
donald trump said when he was asked
about black lives matter he says what
about white people who get killed and
now
all of a sudden here we go how dare you
make this about
another it's like okay well what about
the statistics that that's true because
that is true
you know it's like but it's just he
wasn't wrong it's like they're trying to
tear
it's like they're i think it's because
they they know they're not offering
anything tangible
to minority voters not just the black
community but latinos asians it's true
and trump is in the polls gaining and
that means he wins
yep and i wonder if you know they talk
about how the polls are unable to
capture non-college educated whites
i wonder how effective the polls are at
capturing you know the
like the black community vote if these
are if these are communities that were
taken for granted by all political
parties for a long time
yeah regardless republican and democrat
then i don't know if the pollsters can
effectively track these demographic
changes
like the rise of the black conservative
and stuff like that yeah yeah
and then we might be seeing these polls
what may
what may be skewing the polls is that
it may they may be all true yeah trump
is losing support among certain white
voters
so biden is leading but the polls may be
ignoring certain minority communities
because they've never had to pull in
this way before that's a good point
so trump could actually be way up and
we're going to see something
like we saw in 2016 when the polls were
all saying hillary was going to win
the probability said she was going to
win and then afterwards they went well
we
knew we couldn't actually survey these
you know
right non-college-educated white people
so we
didn't realize how wrong we were going
to be you know uh you just said
something too the
rise of the black conservative that's
inaccurate
it's actually the return of the black
conservative
because that that is a lot of the black
conservatives are the ones that were
really
making the leaps and bounds in civil
rights
in in the the in in our history so
they were prevalent i think it's i think
it's the
i don't know what it is i don't know
maybe it's that people are becoming less
uh some people are are too scared to
speak up some people are less scared to
speak up
yeah you know what's interesting too
about the arguments i've been talking
about a lot
about people refusing to speak up is
that there are so many people who have
found
success in speaking out
there are people have been canceled who
have turned it into a career
there there have been people who weren't
even canceled but started saying
unpopular things and found their
audience
good point and there are people who are
hiding in the in their closet
hoping that when the reaper comes to
their door they'll be the
one house he just skips over yep sorry
it's not going to work that way
well i'm certainly speaking up i'm
exhausted mentally exhausted from
the amount of re-explaining i have to do
because
you know it's really hard to to just
simply say
oh sure here's all of the five months of
research that i've been doing and the
hundreds of hours that i've had with you
know with you on this show
and you know outside of the show that we
talk about things that are going on it's
like how do i
con like quantify all that and just a
simple response on facebook
well why are you voting for him it's
like okay
you can't do it no i know and that's
that's and but
but it's it's not about facebook because
now i've had
certain people reach out to me outside
of facebook
hey talk to me about what what what is
it about him that you like what what
why are you voting why are you voting
like that and those few people
i people on twitter are like dude just
don't worry about them there's going to
be haters
and it's like no we we have to talk i i
have we have to speak up
we've been talking about it we have to
have these conversations
i'm civil and some of them don't agree
with me and some of them are like you
know what
that's fine i'm still not going to vote
for trump but
i'm glad we had this conversation it's
like yes even
i'm not trying to sway anyone but i'm
sick of the
the lies that i'm seeing and i'm calling
them out and that's kind of why i wanted
to have that conversation
it feels like you know i i grew up with
all these people saying
the war was bad protesting war in iraq
and afghanistan
yeah and now here we are and when i
actually asked one of my friends who's
like same age as me
chicago liberal yep would you support
pulling out the troops from afghanistan
yes of course right no no no really
there's like a uh oh wait a minute
oh is this a trap i know what tim thinks
and so the response is no longer we must
pull out
the response is now well
maybe but and i'm like
are you kidding me do you have an
original thought in your brain
look man you can complain about all the
worst things in the world from obama
from trump from anybody
but if you have stood on this uh hit if
you have said in this hill
that we should not be in the middle east
right and trump says
okay i'll pull out of the middle east
you can't also be like well no actually
i think
no you say all right well you know okay
i'll take it i guess
someone asked me the other day why why
are they
against pulling against the troops and
that's why i asked you yesterday and
it's like the war machine
the the russia contracts all these
you know things and i'm like i've looked
into it and i still have yet to find
a nice legitimate answer there is
in terms of the actions being taken on
the lease but the first thing you can
say you can look at a map and see that
iraq and afghanistan are on both sides
of iran and
john bolton you know who was advising
trump for a while and they got outed and
then turned on you know that was a
mistake
he was bragging he wanted to invade iran
yep and so
it has a lot to do with oil is a lot to
do with resources
it has a lot to its regional power it is
it has a lot to do with competing for
natural uh resources
so there's a there's this big
international isn't it always
right i mean it's energy energy equals
expansion expansion equals
you know cultural expansion and so we're
up we're competing with china
and a bunch of other interests to expand
and
china is is rapidly gaining ground
so i can't tell you what they want from
iran maybe maybe it has to do with
defending israel
controlling the region you know israel
is constantly under threat and the us
is definitely trying to you know
stabilize there's a lot of reasons
i'm sure i'm sure there's a lot of
people who just do it for money i'm sure
there's a lot of people do it for
ideological reasons a lot of people who
do it for
um strategic reasons for dominance
around the world
but in the end there's a lot of people
in this country who are sick of it
and have wanted for a long time first of
all we've never we should have never
gone over there
and now wants to return how is it that
there are people who are now serving in
the military who were born after we
invaded
yep you know that's the craziest thing
to me or at least that's like a talking
point to say like we are now at that
point
but trump comes along and i'm sitting
here and like my position's long been
like
one of the only things i really care
about first before we can move on is is
bringing our soldiers home and not being
this invading force in these foreign
countries
and then everything just stops when
trump goes okay
i'm like wait what he's like yeah and
i'm like wait
wait you're actually gonna do it yeah
it's like it's something
something that i've been saying for a
long time like we gotta stop the war
machine and stop being the world police
and
almost every single person i know that
is arguing with me now
has felt that way you know they flip and
now they support being the world police
well i mean i
you can't have a rational conversation
so i've never got there i haven't i
haven't been able to even get to that
point
in in the conversation you know i i
listed all of the things that i've found
that are good that he's done and that's
that's on there that's like
one of the things and they're just like
that's not good enough
he's friends with nazis and i'm like
what where
where are you getting your information
hillary clinton so i simply just said
now is when you show me your source oh
yeah right and i have yet to hear back
exactly
yeah but i'm not gonna i'm not gonna not
have a civil conversation i'm not gonna
like
become emotional you know i want to have
all the facts i'm laying them all out
i'm going to continue doing so
these these people who think that we're
the empire from star wars
yeah you like they think that america is
the worst imperial foreign invading
country
okay well you've got your choice of
biden who was part of the obama
administration working with hillary
clinton and
exacerbating these problems yep and you
have donald trump who's being blocked as
he tried to return he tries to bring the
troops back
yep this is why this is what look i
didn't i i voted for obama the first
time the second time
right because he was like we're gonna
bring our troops home and then he gets
in and he's like more troops
and then they started blowing up kids
and and civilians and then calling on
enemy combatants and stuff oh they're
military age you know
that's that's good enough for us and so
i was like yeah right
i'm not going to fall for this again and
i did i did not vote 2012 i did not vote
in 2016.
now i'm at a point where for one yeah
cancel culture pc culture
the weird intersectionalism freaks me
out but then trump's like
even though i didn't vote for him he's
talking about bringing our troops back
and i'm like
okay he didn't he didn't promise me to
do anything
i didn't vote for him he's literally
just doing it he's not just saying we
got to bring our troops home
he's he's going into detail we need to
stop being
the world police we need to focus on our
infrastructure
making our roads better helping our
minority communities which he is doing
and it's like how are they ignoring that
now this is some this is one of the
biggest reasons why i thought
i didn't like him because i didn't think
that he was for that because i didn't
actually listen
to to the right people to the right
things to the actual policies that he
was putting
here's what i'm saying when obama made
me that promise like we're gonna do all
these great things we're gonna bring our
troops back
and i was like i like what he's selling
i'm gonna buy
yep vote and then what did he do one of
the first things he did was he bombed a
village of women and children looking
for an enemy combatant or something yep
and i was like that's not what i paid
for i mean that metaphorically not
literally
i'm like whoa whoa whoa whoa i come into
a shop and i say one slice of pepperoni
pizza
you give me some weird you know veggie
tofu stuff i'm gonna be like hey hey
whoa i get it some people might want you
you know to do certain things but that's
not what i asked for that's what you
promised me right
i didn't vote for trump i actually i
laughed when he won and i didn't care
i'm like yeah well you know what i was
totally disenfranchised
disaffected now trump's being they're
resisting him trying to bring the troops
back and i'm like
that's the biggest thing to me i don't
care about anything else it's like well
what about trump and it's very fine
people i don't care
wait wait hold on you you think that
because trump said naughty words
i'm supposed to not support the idea
that we're gonna
pull our imperialistic star wars
stormtrooper troops out of the middle
east
back home bring them back to their
family you think this is the empire from
star wars
you think that it's better for joe biden
to get in and send
more people over there just so he can
say nice words to you
trump could go on a foul mouth tirade
for five hours
cussing using every slur in the book and
then if he said
and after all that here's an executive
order i am ordering all the troops to
return tomorrow i'd be like okay
i don't care what he said because you
know i've
he's doing it he's trying to do it now
yeah that's why i kind of feel like
his promises are meaningless if he said
trust me re-elect me and i'll do it i'd
be like yeah right
right i'm not buying it but he's
straight up doing it and so i'm like i
wanna i wanna help him do that
i wanna i wanna i wanna end that i don't
like that i don't i've never liked that
and i've actually been somebody
to to you know i've uh i was in egypt
during the revolution yeah
i don't pretend like i was in
afghanistan or iraq or anything like
that but i've i've covered a lot of this
uh this national security news
for a decade and i understand a lot of
the complexities
of it i've heard the debates and i just
can't square away what we do over there
with my morals and my ethics and along
comes a president who without asking
without telling me
like i need your vote to do this he just
started doing it and i'm like oh
yeah and and that a few different people
were
were like yelling at me for for
supporting
a nazi supporter basically and i'm like
what is this from
and it all boiled down to that one fake
speech and i was like okay
i wasn't paying attention then i'll go
look at the speech and i'll listen to
what he's saying
and i did and the very first thing out
of his mouth
i do not condone any neo-nazis they
should all like go
away they should be condemned totally
period
and then he moves on and they're like
well well what about what about the the
people that were there and he's like
i'm sure not everybody there was a
neo-nazi they were
they were against the statues coming
down he was right and i was like
okay that makes sense to me and he was
talking about the people that
specifically were not the neo-nazis you
know what's funny
how come the right didn't go trump just
defended antifa
trump is defending marxist and violent
communists
did you hear him said there's very fine
people on both sides on both sides that
was trump defending neo-marxists
i guess communists violent
authoritarians
no it doesn't go otherwise tim it
doesn't go both ways exactly
politics flow and politics flows in one
direction that's true
it's it's like well tech away from the
left
so if you are seen in a video with a guy
wearing a maga hat and you're smiling
a thumbs up they'll be like adam's a
trump supporter now wait till i actually
put on a magazine but then wait but then
wait
if you're caught in a photo sitting next
to anti-fog giving a thumbs up they'll
go
that anti-guy is a is a trump supporter
now you get it
yep it's it's only one direction
so when trump says both sides had good
people the media doesn't say trump
defends communists
they say trump defends nazis even though
he didn't in fact hold on hold on
trump i i dare say that's a new teacher
we need to make i dare say
donald trump condemned the nazis did
donald trump in that speech condemn
communists he did not therefore
it is more apt to say donald trump
actually defended communists as very
fine people
it makes more sense because if you
actually go through his speech yeah
that's true because he actually
condemned the neo-nazis
specifically that's true that's the only
only people that he did condemn in that
speed
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8 pm if you
want to catch the full show tune in to
this channel subscribe
hit the like button or check us out on
itunes and spotify and we will soon have
this podcast up for free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you